as we speak the few hospitals still
functioning
are attending
life-threatening burn
bullet and shrapnel injuries with many
unattended at home
or in the streets with these injuries
or with tuberculosis
depression and psychiatric drug
disorders diabetes
hiv covets and cancer
40 percent of households have at least
one member in need of chronic treatment
that they can no longer find
resulting
in an estimated at least three thousand
premature avoidable deaths direct impact
of the conflict after two months is
appalling
at least 3382
civilian deaths among which 75 girls and
91 boys
and 69 children whose sex is yet unknown
13 million people displaced
and 16 million people in need of
assistance
these are dark times for the european
region
confronted with unthinkable levels of
human suffering
shadow cast from over two years of a
pandemic
we are now experiencing war and the
greatest humanitarian crisis
our european countries have experienced
for more than 70 years
with almost 200 health attacks verified
and documented by who on the ground
ukraine sees the largest and quickest
assault
on the healthcare system its workforce
and its patience
don't all what has been said already
don't the firmest condemnation for this
ex
i need to say that nothing is more
destructive to health
than attacking it up front
effects of this conflict will cascade
down through generations to come
i firmly stand beside the united nations
secretary general guterres
in urging all parties
to enact an urgent and immediate
humanitarian ceasefire